when i first got to know you it was well
this is a
former second city guy
uh who probably was interested in sketch
comedy and then
got into very quickly when you came out
to l.a you got that walking dead gig so
quick like within a matter of months
yeah literally in like half six months i
got i got that did you have any
disappointment before you got that gig i
did i had um i i was out for pilot
season and i had auditioned for this
uh network pilot that i got to the last
stage it was me and this other guy
and i didn't get it and i was like
decimated that day i was i they've told
this story but like i was eating at ihop
by myself and like well that's first of
all that's a sign of trouble right away
that's up there with drinking alone
you can't go to an ihop alone by
yourself give me all the pancakes
all of them it was it was mr yun please
all of them it was not great
and so yeah i i got a phone call there
saying i didn't get it
and i thought it was done
and then you know
two months later
the thing that i couldn't have gotten if
i had gotten yes original thing yeah so
i don't know
after that i just
stopped
i mean i still bug out but i stopped
like forcing it well you know i this
this hits on one of
the great lessons i try to impart to
people which is
and i've said this
many times but i keep repeating it
because i think it's so elemental and
true
there are these disappointments that you
hit along the way and i you know believe
i've said this but i was convinced it
was my destiny to be a writer for late
night with david letterman like my like
that is the key
you know and it almost feels like lord
of the rings if i don't i need to cross
that bridge to get to the other side i'm
just trying to pull gorilla in i need to
cross that bridge
i love bridges
kate's by the way by the way hates uh
all tolkien and uh lord of the rings but
any kind of bridge talk he says
we'll talk we talked for an hour about
the triborough the other day we're doing
the suspensions next week yeah we are
okay we'll get to it that's next week
just excited it's next week it's next
week and i have the specs you asked for
thank you um but no it it felt like the
only way to get to the magic land is
i i need to uh be doing for dave
um
you know uh what um
you know i need to be a writer on that
show and i need to do some performing on
that show and that's i just felt that
that was
the thing that had to happen and when it
didn't happen i thought well that's it
now if i later on helicopter route i
call it google earth if you pull way out
and look at your whole life
if that had happened i would not have
worked for lauren michaels who would not
have noticed me and thought hmm maybe
that idiot could run uh could be a talk
show host
um
none of that would have ever happened if
the thing i wanted it you know and uh to
happen happened so
i wouldn't change a thing and that
includes a lot of missteps and disasters
along the way but
people need to know that they need to
know that because in that moment when
you're sitting in an ihop
yeah and you get that call yeah and you
just look at the waitress and go like
more
more syrups
wait i go to an ihop alone every morning
what am i doing wrong
we're doing right okay no no no you're
doing all right you're doing you that's
you all right it's not sad when you do
it yeah yeah yeah okay for me it's a
celebration to go to ihop alone
well now you have twins oh yeah yeah so
going alone going anywhere alone i mean
you've been through this you have two
young kids yeah yeah uh and i am no
longer in that boat my kids are are
teenagers but when they were little
if someone said we have an iron maiden
here you know
we're going to lock you in it
uh and spikes are going to go into your
flesh i would say would i be alone
well yeah so my my kids wouldn't be with
me
no okay
mr o'brien we're supposed to lock you in
it you're not supposed to jump into it
and shut it behind no calls i said no
calls